dans cette campagne seul souci c'est de
permettre du rassemblement
notre pays ne va pas rien pour
particulier parce que de gestion du
pouvoir actuel est un gestion solidaire
arbitres
péremptoire
la france n'est pas grand coppel et se
taire et n'est pas forte si le cas
roberge
je suis déterminé à être le président
d'une france réconciliée
le respecterai les français que je ferai
respecter la france
direct qui incarne une certaine france
qui est bien c'est à dire une france qui
est calme qui est sereine
avoir un candidat qui est resté dans
notre famille politique c'est très
importante les militants ça leur fait
chaud au coeur vous êtes parmi ces
l'expérience le plus beau cv de la
république il reste ouvert aux idées
neuves que nous les jeunes on peut lui
apporter
je crois au projet je crois en l'homme
et je suis prêt aujourd'hui à donner
andy scolarité pour qu'ils puissent
gagner
puisqu'après un an scolarité ça se
rattrape 50 emmanuel macron ça se
rattrape mois quand même
[Musique]
bien cher michel
je ne sais pas si tu veux le micro du
pit
[Musique]
comment
chères amies et chers compagnons bonjour
merci et de votre présence et de votre
attention
je suis pour beaucoup de raisons très
heureux d'être là et de vous saluer dans
la diversité des départements que vous
représentez du nord au sud de la france
de l'est à l'ouest en passant par la
savoie évidemment de la corse de nos
territoires
d'outre-mer et je pense en particulier
aujourd'hui et pour les jours qui
viennent à la nouvelle calédonie est
bien actuellement des français de
l'étranger qui sont trois millions et
demi nous ne les oublions pas vous avez
des convictions nous avons des
convictions
nous avons l'amour de notre pays ancrée
au plus profond de notre coeur et vous
êtes là vous avez toujours été là car
l'enjeu qui mobilise notre mouvement
comme l'on dit à l'instant
christian jacob et annie genevard c'est
un enjeu capital pour l'avenir de notre
pays et moi je voudrais aussi vous
remercier très personnellement de
l'accueil que j'ai reçu que je reçois
dans chacune des fédérations je peux
aller des présidents de département des
secrétaires départementaux du
conseillers fédéraux des militants et
des jeunes républicains en particulier
je voudrais aussi dire un mot de
remerciement christian jacob malgré des
défections malgré les trahisons malgré
ce qu'ils voulaient en finir avec les
républicains au motif que nous étions
trop à droite il a mis son énergie sa
mobilité sa solidité sa ténacité son
opiniâtreté de l'agriculteur au service
d'autres familles politiques pour
qu'elles soient rassemblées et question
grâce à ton et pulsion
les républicains que nous sommes et vous
avez beaucoup participé à cela on
produit sous la coordination d'olivier
marc l'ex de christine lagarde un projet
puissant qui restera pour nous tous pour
moi en tout cas le socle de notre projet
pour la france merci aussi à daniel
fasquelle pour avoir redressé les
comptes
mouvement donc à mon tour je voudrais
christian de dire personnellement si je
le pensais pas je le dirai pas un mot
personnel de remerciement pour la
solidité que tu as démontré et qui a
était communicative pour notre mouvement
jérémy j'étais à vos côtés hier je l' ai
toujours été je le suis aujourd'hui
adhérents militants comme chacun et
chacune d'entre vous mais aussi comme
nicolas sarkozy qui en dépit des
épreuves n'a jamais quitté notre parti
ceux qui l'ont abandonné
ceux qui l'ont abandonnée par tactique
personnel souvent pour aller rejoindre
le pouvoir notamment nous ont fragilisés
et grâce à vous tous nous avons tenu
mieux nous avons gagné les municipales
et régionales et sénatoriales les
élections départementales et
législatives partielles et encore cette
semaine le relais réussi très réussie
grâce au maire à nos mères entre
françois baroin et david lisnard
et dans cette introduction de
remerciments je voudrais dire mon
particulier et personnel à valérie
pécresse
eric ciotti un philippe juvin à xavier
bertrand pour l'esprit de cette
compétition le respect le dialogue nous
en avons besoin nous en aurons besoin
puisqu'il est clair qu'au lendemain de
cette élection qui sera celle des
militants le temps des militants qui
doit être respectée c'est eux et
personne d'autre ni les sondages des
rumeurs et les petites phrases qui
feront l'élection ce sont les militants
au lendemain de cette élection le 4 e
soir nous allons nous retrouver nous
devrons nous retrouver une seule équipe
un seul projet un projet pour la france
le projet de la droite républicaine et
du centre que nous porterons aux
élections présidentielles voilà je
voudrais à tous les quatre leur dire mon
respect et l'engagement que j'ai pris
dans toutes mes réunions et que je
confirme devant vous de tout faire pour
que cette réunion de ses candidats et
avec eux de tout le parti soit solide
durable et convaincante mes chers amis
je connais votre attente qui est
légitime après 10 ans du couple hollande
macron qui a causé tant de tort à la
france nous en avons assez et le temps
est venu de réparer notre pays jeudi
réparer parce que les dégâts sont
considérables
vous ne voulez plus nous ne voulons plus
allégée de celui qui a reculé dès le
début de son mandat face aux à dist de
notre dame des landes
de celui qui a laissé prospérer le
désordre de celui qui considère qu'il
n'existe pas vraiment de culture
française du premier président qui n'a
pas été en mesure de conduire à bien la
réforme des retraites nous avons vu ce
qu'il en coûte à la france d'être
soumise à cet exercice solitaire très
solitaire du pouvoir une france
fractures et des français souvent ignoré
un parlement marginalisés et des
syndicats laissés de côté pas un jour ne
se passe sans que des faits de
délinquance majeur ne provoque la colère
ou l'effroi nos compatriotes pas un jour
sans qu'une centaine de policiers de
gendarmes de pompiers d'élus ne soit
agressé dans l'exercice de leurs
fonctions au service de notre sécurité
d'autres protections voilà les symptômes
de l'effondrement de l'autorité de
l'état de ce que j'ai appelé ce que je
considère être le grand déclassement de
notre pays
emmanuel macron n'a pas compris la
france ni les français
la taxe sur les carburants n'a été
d'ailleurs qu'une illustration d'une
vision punitive de l'écologie ce n'est
pas la mienne nous savons la souffrance
de ceux qui n'arrivent plus à boucler
leurs fins de mois pour satisfaire ses
alliés verts on a sacrifié fessenheim
mettant en péril notre industrie
nucléaire qui nous permet pourtant de
produire souverainement une électricité
décarbonés beaucoup moins cher qu'en
allemagne au fond emmanuel macron a été
élu en renversant la table disait-il en
cinq ans il ne fait que fragiliser la
france emmanuel macron avait été élu
pour faire des réformes il n'aura donné
que des leçons
en dépensant l'argent public sans
compter mais elle macron ne fait preuve
d'aucune sorte d'héroïsme il est en
revanche responsable d'endetter la
france sans égard pour nos enfants nos
petits enfants qui devront tôt ou tard
faire face à la remontée des taux
d'intérêt
les années qui viennent
viennent de s'écouler nous l'ont montré
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
s'improviser président de la république
et donc puisqu'il faut changer de
politique et c'est notre volonté c'est
notre ambition il faudra changer de
président rami je me présente devant
vous
tel que je suis je n'ai pas de plan de
carrière mais un plan de bataille
je vous propose une autre méthode
je propose une autre méthode je crois
depuis très longtemps
en la morale collective de l'action
qu'évoquer georges pompidou dans son
livre le noeud gordien dans chacune de
mes responsabilités j'ai toujours veillé
à créer le collectif
aujourd'hui je suis prêt et je suis
préparée je sais ce qu'il faut changer
et je sais comment nous allons changer
je n'ai rien oublié de tout ce que j'ai
appris et j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai
encore beaucoup à apprendre d'eux
tholomé responsabilité est d'abord en
savoie comme jeune conseiller général
président pendant 17 ans de ce
département avec de grands projets de
plus petits à quatre reprises j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être nom du gouvernement de
notre république sous l'autorité de
jacques chirac d'abord et de nicolas
sarkozy ensuite et puis dans ses
responsabilités internationales et
européennes d'apprendre que notre pays
est un grand pays qu'il doit faire
l'effort au delà de la volonté de le
rester pour cela il faut chaque jour
veiller plus que ça n'a été fait depuis
dix ans à l' influence de notre pays et
à sa capacité de peser sur le monde et
sur l'europe à chaque fois j'ai cherché
des résultats avec opiniâtreté pour
reprendre un mot qui était cher et avec
ténacité j'ai aussi mesurer à quel point
la france étaient bloqués et combien et
sur quoi l'europe doit être changée au
moi je se laissa après cinq années de
négociations difficiles avec les
britanniques et je sais aussi que si
nous ne changeons pas ce qui doit l'être
à bruxelles et en europe alors il y aura
d'autres préc site voilà je vous le dit
avec fermeté avec conviction de
protégeant notre culture de protégeant
notre vie de mode de vie attaqué au
quotidien nous assumerons notre histoire
toute notre histoire sans nous excuser
et sans repentance
nous mettrons progressivement fin aux
zones de non droit pour reprendre un mot
que nadine morano qui doit être ici a
dénoncé très très tôt nous livrons une
guerre sans merci contre le terrorisme
et contre ceux qui propagent un islam
politique est radical qui gangrène notre
société nous interdirons le port du
voile à l'université et dans le
périmètre de nos services publics
en france chers amis chers compagnons on
ne soumet pas les filles on ne soumet
pas les femmes elles sont libres elles
sont les égales de l'homme
c'est tout simplement notre constitution
et nos valeurs nos compatriotes sont à
bout de vivre la sécurité partout les
rodéos les réponses pénales insuffisante
l'immigration devenu trop nombreuses et
qui ne permet plus désormais ni
d'intégration ni l'assimilation
ce sont des préalables il a dit annick
on en parlait beaucoup je pense en effet
que on en parle beaucoup mais parce que
ce sont les sujets les plus graves il ya
tout le reste et pour moi ce sont les
préalables qui permettront si nous
traitons correctement et rapidement ces
questions de sécurité d'autorité de
l'état d' immigration maîtrisée et
préalable qui permettront de retrouver
la sécurité la sérénité la tranquillité
dont les français ont envie et besoin et
nous permettront aussi d'engager très
vite immédiatement avec plus de force et
de sérénité la reconstruction sur tous
les autres sujets où il ya tant à faire
le travail et le mérite plutôt que
l'assistanat le pouvoir d'achat
l'ascenseur social il faut faire
redémarrer l'éducation et la santé la
famille et les retraites naturellement
l'accueil des personnes handicapées la
culture donc lui a parlé et puis aussi
ce sujet qui pour moi est fondamentale
dès l'instant où on décide d'être
européen en plus d'être patriote et
d'être actif dans les institutions
internationales
l'influencé française qui ne se décrète
pas et qu'ils ne tombent pas du ciel
j'aurais mis les français méritent
d'être respectés
c'est le sens de ma candidature je
respecterai les français et je ferai
respecter la france à l'extérieur mais
aussi à l'intérieur par ceux qui ne la
respectent plus ni les lois de la
république
je n'accomplirai qu'un seul mandat c'est
le bon sens et la raison avec des
priorités claires et des résultats mais
toujours avec le souci de la
transmission qui a toujours été le mien
est donc un seul mandat ça veut dire que
c'est un premier mandat que doit être
confiée à notre famille politique il
faudra ensuite je ferai cela préparer
les relais et la transmission pour faire
leur choix en conscience les français
n'ont pas besoin me semble-t-il qu'on
leur propose un catalogue de mesures
techniques ou impossible à mettre en
oeuvre ils ont besoin d'un cap clair ce
cap clair je vous le propose autour de
trois grandes priorités je vous le dis
je le redis nous y reviendrons dans
notre dialogue la première d'entre elles
c'est le rétablissement de l'ordre grâce
à un électrochoc d'autorité nous ferons
en sorte que soit appliqué des sanctions
fermes et rapides
après aider le premier délit et que ces
sanctions soient immédiatement exécuté
plus de juge la double peine des peines
planchers de nouvelles places de prison
et quatre fois plus de places en centres
éducatifs fermés il faut en finir nous
en finirons avec l'impunité
[Applaudissements]
la deuxième priorité le second préalable
c'est évidemment de mettre un coup
d'arrêt à l'immigration devenu
incontrôlable en ce qui me concerne je
n'ai jamais fait partie de ceux qui
jugeaient par exemple laurent wauquiez
trop à droite à ce sujet pour porter
pour porter un coup d'arrêt à
l'immigration mieux intégré mieux
accueillir ce que nous voulons
accueillir un peu meilleure plus digne
et faire en sorte que la part des
étrangers dans notre population cesse
d'augmenter commence même à se réduire
nous restreindre ont drastiquement le
regroupement familial qui est devenue
une filière d'immigration
nous supprimerons l'immigration social
avec la fin de l'aide médicale d'état
sauf l'urgence
mais pour cela
les français seront consultés à
l'automne par référendum un référendum
dont les termes seront proposés par nos
candidats aux élections législatives dès
le mois de juin ils trancheront alors le
peuple tranchera cinq points sur
l'immigration des quotas votée par le
parlement chaque année un bouclier
constitutionnel pour reprendre le
contrôle que nous avons perdus dans
l'essence empiler des jurisprudences
nationales et européennes toujours plus
favorable aux étrangers l'état
le deuxième point portera sur l'état de
nécessité antiterroriste qui sera
inscrit dans la constitution
la suppression du droit de sol à mayotte
et en guyane
l'inscription dans l'article 3 de la
constitution du principe important
proposé par philippe bassot sénat et par
les sénateurs chez renault selon lequel
nul ne saurait se prévaloir de sa
religion de son origine pour se
soustraire à la loi commune
et nous reprendrons notre relation avec
les pays d'émigration en conditionnant
l'aide au développement dont ils ont
besoin et c'est aussi notre intérêt à le
re décision d'accepter à nouveau de
réadmettre les étrangers chez nous qui
sont leurs citoyens et de ne voulons
plus chez nous avec aussi dans cette
coopération un axe important qui est la
lutte contre les trafics d'hommes de
femmes d'enfants la lutte contre la
drogue la troisième priorité si vous le
voulez bien sera celle de rétablir le
sérieux budgétaire et de mes de miser
sur la production permettez moi de
rendre hommage à nos fonctionnaires aux
militaires à tous les fonctionnaires
nous en connaissons tous nous en
comptons tous dans nos familles je ne
fais pas partie de ceux qui les
considère simplement comme des chiffres
et comme
et comme celles et ceux qui sont notre
première ligne de défense dans la vie
quotidienne pour notre protection et
pour faire face aux crises je ne les
considérait pas comme une variable
d'ajustement campagne électorale et je
ne m'inscris donc pas dans un concours
pour savoir lequel d'entre nous
promettra le plus de suppressions de
postes tellement de candidats ont
proposé de supprimer des postes de
fonctionnaires pour ne jamais le faire
nous avons besoin d'un état souple
réactifs capables de réduire les
effectifs là où ils sont excessifs de
les augmenter là où ils sont nécessaires
par exemple dans tous les domaines
régaliens
ensuite la santé de l'éducation de la
justice j'estime que nos fonctionnaires
et nos militaires doivent être mieux
payés pour cela nous devrons faire des
économies en luttant enfin sérieusement
contre la fraude fiscale et sociale nous
institueront
et nous demanderons pour cela aux
français
de faire l'effort de changer chacun et
chacune leur carte vitale pour faire une
vérification biométrique de tous ceux
qui ont le droit
ou qui n'ont pas le droit à
des services d'assurance santé nous
devons faire des économies en luttant
pour le bonnes pratiques beaucoup
d'entre vous sont maires élus régionaux
et départementaux je pense dans la
région qui est la mienne celle que
dirige avec autorité laurent wauquiez a
la capacité qu'il a eu avec son équipe
de réduire les dépenses de
fonctionnement sans diminuer la qualité
des services publics
l'hôpital de valenciennes que vous
connaissez tourne seulement avec 5% de
personnes administratif c'est donc
possible nous devrons faire aussi un
ménage méthodique qui prendra du temps
pour lutter contre ce délire
bureaucratique des normes et des
standards qui après abl nos créateurs
nos artisans nos commerçants nos
agriculteurs nos entrepreneurs voilà
chars et mis l'argent magique n'existe
pas et le pouvoir d'achat ne se décrète
pas c'est en travaillant davantage en
produisant davantage et mieux en
investissant davantage en france que
nous accroîtrons notre niveau de vie
d'autres pays les impôts les charges les
taxes représentent 60% du chiffre
d'affaires des entreprises contre 40%
chez nos voisins et la france s'impose
une concurrence déloyale par son niveau
d'imposition délirant et par une
implication différencier toujours plus
défavorable pour nos agriculteurs des
entrepreneurs des directives européennes
voilà pour la réduction des dépenses de
fonctionnement nous finançons un choc de
production en divisant par deux les
impôts de production en baissant les
charges sur les salaires intermédiaire
parce que je crois une économie des bons
salaires le premier emploi d'un jeune
sera exonéré de toutes ces charges pour
les trois premières années et nous
atteindrons le chiffre de huit cent
mille apprentis ce que nous voulons pour
notre pays c'est une politique familiale
reconstruite qui a été méthodiquement
démoli par hollande et macron c'est
aussi du travail plus que l'assistanat
voilà chers amis j'ai enfin toujours une
conviction au fond de moi même depuis
mon tout premier engagement c'est que la
cohésion sociale c'est un levier c'est
un moteur de la compétitivité le combat
pour l'homme sont les mots qui sont
inscrits sous la croix de lorraine à
colombes et où nous étions tous ensemble
autre jour un participation et
l'intéressement des travailleurs ainsi
nous retrouverons notre rang et nous
deviendrons comme je le crois possible
et nécessaire la première puissance
économique et agricole d'europe dans 10
ou 15 ans la première puissance
décarbonée voilà je vais conclure en me
sens maintenant le temps pour vous de
poser des questions de m'interroger de
m'interpeller je vous répondrais
sincèrement dans cette famille politique
d'un autre où j'ai toujours été fidèle
je rassemblerai les français oui je
serai un présent sérieux très sérieux
parce que la présence de république
c'est quelque chose de très sérieux
aujourd'hui je m'adressais à chaque
français et en particulier aux plus
jeunes qui veulent croire en quelque
chose de plus grand qu'eux mêmes
car au delà de nos petites différences
ou de divergence quelquefois il y à la
france aujourd'hui je m'adressais à
chaque français prêts à se retrousser
les manches pour son pays il n'y aura
pas de baguette magique il y aura
seulement un sursaut collectif retrouvé
le bonheur retrouvé la fierté d'être
français
écrire une nouvelle page de l'épopée de
notre patrie c'est notre cap j'ai plus
que besoin plus que jamais besoin de
vous c'est aussi le sens de ce message
pour être grâce à vous et avec vous un
président qui respectera les français
qui fera respecter la france merci de
leur attachement
merci michel
non chers amis
je vous rappelle les règles
donc il reste trente minutes pour les
questions réponses les questions doivent
être brève pas plus d'une minute donc je
vous demande vraiment vous confirmer de
façon à ce qu'il puisse y avoir un
maximum des changes il ya quatre micros
disposées dans la salle on vous donnera
alternativement le bleu le jaune le
rouge et l'orangé vous le donnez vous
donnera le terreau nativement la parole
alors pour lancer la discussion cher
michel chers candidats aurélia et moi
nous allons vous poser chacun une
question et puis après on enclenchera
avec la salle michel après l'élection
présidentielle dont nous espérons et
dont nous pensons qu'elle est à notre
portée il y à une autre élection
déterminante qui est celle des
législatives durant ce quinquennat on a
eu en face de nous un pouvoir hyper
centralisateur et un parlement qui a
souvent été piétinée or l' équilibre de
la vème république celle équilibre des
pouvoirs précisément un exécutif fort
mais un parlement fort quel est selon
toi la bonne façon de gouverner avec en
lien avec le parlement et quel est le
bon équilibre des pouvoirs pour toi
cher à nice
je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
le premier grand reproche que l'on peut
faire à monsieur macron c'est cette
gestion solitaire
arrogant parfois méprisante j'ai été
comme tous très frappé de voir
la manière dont il a tenu à distance le
parlement les collectivités
territoriales notamment au moment de la
crise qui aurait au contraire me
justifier un travail en commun immédiat
on a d'ailleurs vu que les régions les
départements les communes étaient
beaucoup plus agile mobile que ne
l'était l'état avec les ars
et sans parler des syndicats qu'il a
laissée de côté
des portes qu'il a fermé en rejetant les
propositions par exemple de jean louis
borloo sur la ville et au milieu de tout
ça il ya le parlement rien dans la
constitution de la vème république
n'oblige le président à agir ainsi tout
seul
j'ai d'ailleurs pris le temps d'aller
l'autre jour dialoguer avec un homme que
je respecte dont j'ai été le ministre
edouard balladur et qui sait de quoi il
parle parce qu'il a été le conseiller de
georges pompidou alors président premier
ministre du général de gaulle il a été
lui aussi à l'elysée avec georges
pompidou président et puis à son tour
premier ministre et la lecture qu'il m'a
dit qu'ils étaient faites notamment par
georges pompidou du temps du général
n'était pas celle là c'est une lecture
où malgré tout ce qu'on racontait le
parlement jouer son rôle et le président
d'ailleurs attaché de l'importance à son
parti et à l'unité dans la diversité de
son parti donc oui le parlement à
travers sa majorité
composée d'un pour le principal le nôtre
celui des républicains et le pôle
centriste qui comptera aura un dialogue
régulier avec le président avec le
gouvernement un gouvernement qui
gouvernera comme la constitution le lui
demande si le président ne fait que
gouverner ne préside pas et puis
parlement qui sera sollicitée sur
beaucoup de sujets commission denquête
commission de contrôle
des missions par exemple que j'ai
l'intention
à travers gouvernants de confier au
parlement qui sera l'examen très rapide
de tous les sujets où nous avons nous
français décidé d'appliquer les
directives européennes de manière
différente des autres pays les mêmes
textes appliquée différemment créant
immédiatement
de la justice ou une concurrence
déloyale je pense aux agriculteurs
notamment sur l'usagé des produits
phytosanitaires donc le parlement sera
saisi de cette question le pouvoir de
contrôler le pouvoir de proposition je
ne crois pas qu'on puisse réussir seul
le présent à public n'a pas la science
infuse il ne peut pas décider de tout
tout seul et nous aurons besoin d'un
parlement actif volontaire en même temps
d'une majorité loyal
michel jeu pour être interrogé sur la
question migratoire jeu pour être
interrogé sur la question européenne sur
nos relations internationales mais il me
semble que nous avons déjà entendu sur
ce sujet et je voulais entendre sur un
autre sujet qui est celui de
l'environnement d'abord c'est un sujet
de préoccupation des français parmi les
premiers n'oublions souvent c'est un
grand sujet de préoccupation pour la
jeunesse et on ne gagne pas une élection
présidentielle on ne préside pas un pays
sans embarquer avec nous la jeunesse
c'est aussi notre histoire le premier
ministère de l'environnement c'est sous
georges pompidou la charte de
l'environnement à valeur
constitutionnelle bien avant qu emmanuel
macron d'année ne serait-ce que l'idée
c'est jacques chirac le grenelle de
l'environnement c'est nicolas sarkozy on
ne relèvera pas les défis économiques et
défis sociaux les défis d'une génération
qui prendra la relève de demain sans
relever le défi environnemental
qu'avons nous à dire au milieu du
brouhaha des lobbyistes et de ceux qui
veulent modifier en profondeur ce que
nous sommes pour traiter de la question
environnementale et en faire un
véritable défi pour la droite et pour la
france
alors
il n'y a pas de projet présidentiel qui
ne soit pas fondée sur la question du
changement climatique et d'une écologie
humaniste et concrète je reprends des
mots il que les humanistes et concrète
que j'ai utilisée il ya assez longtemps
maintenant lorsque j'ai eu l'honneur
d'être ministre de l'environnement
précisément sous l'autorité et edouard
balladur et puisque rien tu évoquais le
tout premier ministre de l'environnement
camille en place georges pompidou après
un très grand discours qu'il avait
prononcé aux états unis je veux juste
rappeler que j'étais membre c'était une
de mes fiertés du cabinet de ce premier
ministre l'environnement robert poujade
ça a été ma toute première mission
publique poujade il expliqué
ce mystère comme celui de l'impossible
ministère de l'impossible et
dans cet engagement dans cette lignée
j'ai continué à travailler dans
l'énumération des étapes
qui aurait pu rappeler précisément ce
que nous avons fait au gouvernement 93
avec une loi de février 95 qui comporte
beaucoup d'avancé et notamment je pense
aux jeunes qui ont des choses à dire et
qu'ils veulent les dire à ces deux mots
que j'ai mis dans la loi française pour
la première fois en 95 on février les
mots de débat public la commission
nationale du débat public que nous avons
créée à cette époque et puis la gestion
des risques j'ai commis plusieurs livres
sur ces sujets d'écologie et
d'environnement et aussi de la gestion
des risques qui restera une grande
priorité pour le prochain quinquennat je
pense qu'il faut nous préparer à
d'autres risques de plus en plus de
problèmes liés au dérèglement climatique
parce que ce que j'ai dans toutes mes
réunions d'ailleurs un degré et demi à
deux degrés de plus dans les 20 ans qui
viennent qui fait pas plus tôt ça change
tout ça change tout et donc il faut se
préparer sans créer de la panique se
rajoutait des peurs comme les tenants du
voc l'isthme madame rousseau où les
verts le fond on n'a pas besoin d'agiter
des peurs il a suffi vingt deux réalités
de problème mais un degré demi ça change
tout j'ai présidé un savon en savoie un
département dont un tiers de l'économie
repose sur la neige
comme c'est le cas des régions de
montagne
j'ai été mise agriculture il ya là des
viticulteurs parmi vous nous savons de
combien de semaines le temps des
vendanges a été accélérée depuis 15 ans
et ça va continuer bonjour j'étais avec
daniel fasquelle à boulogne-sur-mer et
je dis en passant un mot de solidarité à
nos pêcheurs qui continuent d'être
maltraités et par les anglais
et parlez anglais par le gouvernement et
je suis prêt à répondre précisément à
ceux qui se posent des questions sur les
conditions dans lesquelles j'ai négocié
cet accord qui n'est pas bien appliquées
aujourd'hui et qui n'est pas respecté
par les britanniques qui se comportent
comme des flibustiers
à boulogne sur mer je rencontrais des
pêcheurs qui m'expliquait qu'il ne
trouvait plus les mêmes poissons que ce
que pêcher dans les mêmes eaux leur père
ou leur grand-père est lui-même depuis
60 ans ça change tout donc il faut se
préparer c'est pour ça que la réponse
doit être méthodique sérieuse organisé
ça sera la fondation du quinquennat et
dans cette fondation il ya évidemment
l'énergie et la place que nous allons
retrouver pour l'énergie nucléaire on ne
peut pas continuer à tergiverser comme
l'a fait et monsieur hollande puis
monsieur macron sur cette question
fondamentale qui touche à notre
souveraineté et notre capacité rester
libre nous n'avons pas de gaz nous
n'avons pas de pétrole nous avons
l'énergie nucléaire et donc nous allons
relancer est ce que ce sera à 6 8
réacteurs immédiat le programme astrid
nous n'allons pas fermer les réacteurs
qui étaient promis à la fermeture par
monsieur hollande et par monsieur macron
nous allons sans complexe relancer la
production électronucléaire française
qui est une des conditions de notre
souveraineté et en même temps pour être
tout à fait franc moi je ne suis pas
partisan du tout nucléaire
je crois beaucoup à d'autres formes
d'énergie à d'autres diversité je ne
crois pas aux éoliennes je le dis comme
je le pense
mais je crois beaucoup au photovoltaïque
à l'énergie solaire j'ai même en savoie
créée il ya vingt ans l'institut
national du solaire qui fonctionne
toujours aujourd'hui il ya 500
chercheurs qui explique des choses
formidables sur les capacités de
développement de l'énergie solaire et
donc nous allons faire cela la
biodiversité marine et terrestre nous
allons insister aussi sur la protection
des risques et tout cela dans ce que
j'appelle une écologie humaniste et
concrètes qui sera fondée sur le
principe du contrat plutôt que de la
contrainte voilà j'espère avoir dit
simplement ma conviction sur ce sujet
aurélien qui n'est pas nouvelle on peut
d'ailleurs trouver beaucoup de livres
que j'ai publié sur ces questions et ce
sera un engagement pour les générations
futures j'ai parlé de la dette tout à
l'heure il ya plusieurs formes de dettes
il ya la dette financière est la dette
écologique c'est pas moi le premier
qu'il dit que nous ne méritons pas la
terre de nos ancêtres nous l'empruntons
à nos enfants et c'est l'état d'esprit
dans lequel je me trouve
[Applaudissements]
on commence les questions de la salle
donc il faut vous avancez vers un des
quatre micros qui sont dans les allées
chers amis faut donc vous lever et aller
vers les micros
voilà bien à vous monsieur en bleu enfin
la fiche bleus microbes le
bonjour monsieur barnier chose est
d'être venu donc j'ai déjà une
quelques explications nous avons
beaucoup de points en commun
vous pouvez me dire juste qui vous
n'êtes pas ce que je vois pas y est je
mieux de savoir quoi
je suis là oui j'étais vous êtes qui
teber le guen je suis allergique du 04
et conseiller national
donc vous avez travaillé durant des
années à l'europe et j'ai une question
qui va porter sur l'europe et je dirais
même plus sur une potentielle adhésion
vous avez dit devant nos amis de la
presse a eu un moment que vous étiez
personnellement favorable à l'entrée
d'un turquie au sein de l'europe est-ce
que c'est toujours le cas
je connais bien cette question qui était
agité ici ou là je vois les tweets des
uns des autres tout ça ce sont des
petites querelles qui n'ont pas beaucoup
d'intérêt
ce qui compte c'est la vérité parce que
c'est aussi des conditions de loyauté
qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur la turquie
j'en ai parlé hier d'ailleurs avec
valérie boyer à marseille avec des
représentants des français d'origine
arménienne qui doivent être respectées
et soutenu surtout en ce moment
en 2004 d'abord reprenant juste
l'histoire si je peux vous dire les
choses la turquie dont vous parlez a été
le premier pays avec lequel la
communauté économique européenne a
établi un lien très fort qui est le lien
de l'association et ça c'est fait non
pas hier et avant-hier ça se fait en
1963 sous l'autorité du général de
gaulle et du chancelier adenauer contrat
d'association après on en a signé
beaucoup de contrats d'association avec
des pays du bord de la méditerranée et
puis on a continué à avoir des relations
avec la turquie de différente nature
commerciale financière je me souviens
être allé lorsque j'étais ministre des
affaires européennes de jacques chirac
allait inaugurer notre ambassade
française à erevan et j'ai rencontré
cette occasion le président de l'arménie
et je lui ai posé une question sans
malice je lui dis nous sommes en train
de discuter du côté européen d'un
contrat lié aux marchés financiers et
que la turquie est ce que vous y êtes
favorable qu'est ce que vous en pensez
compte tenu de votre relation entre
entre vous et les turcs il m'a répondu
cette phrase dont je me souviens il m'a
dit non continuer du côté européen a
discuté avec les turcs parce que quand
ils disent qu'ils sont orientés vers
vous quand il discute avec vous il ne se
retourne pas
ça m'avait marqué cette phrase donc
l'histoire continue et en 2004 le
gouvernement
de jacques chirac dont je suis le miz
affaires étrangères décide de
d'autoriser l'ouverture des négociations
d'adhésion est donc en effet nous
ouvrons une négociation d'adhésion sans
être sûr monsieur
du bout de la discussion
je suis mise à face de temps gère les
aviez bertrand et secrétaires d'état
dans le même gouvernement valérie
pécresse est
député de la majorité et tout le monde
est d'accord en tout cas je n'ai pas le
souvenir d'avoir entendu des désaccords
à cette époque
et
nous ouvrons cette discussion qui sont
compliqués et
et
les choses chance
et notamment la turquie change et que la
sarkozie à l'époque avaient manifesté en
effet un un désaccord avec cette
ouverture de négociations nous sommes
loyaux et je suis loyal avec le
président chirac et des choses changent
la turquie change profondément
profondément et dans la mauvaise
direction
liberté de la presse la liberté des
juges un gouvernement islamiste et donc
nous changeons de position c'est aussi
ça le pragmatisme moi j'ai appris en
lisant et en écoutant notamment le
général de gaulle et en 2007 nicolas
sarkozy devient président de la
république et nous changeons de position
et nous disons clairement que la turquie
n'a plus vocation à entrer dans l'union
européenne et c'est la position que je
tiens si vous deviez avoir une preuve de
cela
c'est une question importante hier j'ai
montré à documents dont vous vous
souvenez peut-être qui est un petit
document qui a été le document de la
campagne électorale européenne que j'ai
conduite à la demande de nicolas sarkozy
avec rachida dati et beaucoup de ceux
qui sont ici depuis l'île de france et
puis pour toute la france nous avons
d'ailleurs de bons souvenirs de cette
campagne puisqu'on a des élections
européennes ce qui est pas habitude de
réaliser 30% des voix et obtenu 30
sièges au parlement
mais dans ce document publié financé par
notre parti dont xavier bertrand
secrétaire général nous avons cette
phrase dans le programme que j'ai
présentées s'agissant à turquie pays ami
et voisin avec lequel nous entretenons
des relations culturelles politiques
économiques notre position est claire la
turquie doit être un partenaire
privilégié de l'union européenne elle
n'a pas vocation à en devenir membre
c'est toujours ma position
nous allons nous allons passer aux
micros jaune donc il reste 21 minutes
michel et je vois que tu as quatre cinq
personnes qui souhaitent très bien
monsieur barnier bonjour vous êtes vous
à la
voilà présentez-vous jean-michel
segantini j'arrive de la savoie avec
deux autres compagnons
monsieur barbier vous avez parlé de
sécurité je suis un ancien fonctionnaire
de police et j'ai passé 40 ans dans la
police nationale
un président de la république s'est
aussi accompagnée d'un gouvernement et
dans ce gouvernement il ya un ministre
de l'intérieur
monsieur barnier allez vous continuer
comme
macro et comme hollande à avoir des
ministres tels que comme certaines
darmanin
charlot
le dock ou le vidocq de la république
qui est qu'un salaire
j'aimerais savoir si vous allez mettre
en fait un professionnel à ce poste
merci
d'abord un mot de la gouvernance du
gouvernement le gouvernement doit
gouverner
le premier doit gouverner c'est ce
qu'indique clairement la constitution le
président président
est en charge de l'unité nationale des
grandes orientations de la souveraineté
nationale la représentation de notre
pays à l'étranger pour défendre son
influence et ses intérêts sans complexe
le gouvernement gouverne il ya eu dans
le passé un certain nombre de premiers
ministres qui ont gouverné comme c'était
leur rôle
deuxièmement ce que j'ai appris comme
d'autres en étant membre du gouvernement
c'est que si on met trois ans à prendre
son boulot
ce n'est pas sûr de ce qu'on doit faire
si on ne fait pas le bon diagnostic en
arrivant
c'est foutu
plus rien ne bouge en dessous doux et on
fera pas de réforme de l'état et dieu
sait s'il faut réformer l'état avec
l'ensemble des pouvoirs publics s'il n'y
a pas des ministres à chaque position
dans chaque poste compétents courageux
soutenu et qui savent qu'ils doivent
faire tout de suite en arrivant
il y aura pas sous mon mandat si vous le
voulez bien il y aura pas trois
ministres de l'intérieur en trois ans 1
et donc oui il y aura un grand ministre
compétent
immédiatement opérationnelles pour
s'occuper exclusivement de la sécurité
publique ce sera le ministère de
l'intérieur et de la sécurité publique
qui ne s'occupera que de cela en ayant
d'ailleurs sous son autorité
l'administration pénitentiaire et puis
il y aura à côté un ministre qui
s'occupera lui de ce que j'appelle la
nouvelle géographie de la france
travail le contrat avec les territoires
la prise en charge de ce grand projet
qui est ce livre maintenant de la
majorité de nos citoyens de vivre là où
ils ont envie de vivre de l'aménagement
des territoires on va je pense ans
semble retrouver la grande ambition qui
était celle d'olivier guichard et
d'autres avec un aménagement plus
équilibrée et qu'on mette fin à cette
concentration à cette centralisation de
notre pays ça sera notre ministère qui
sera en charge des territoires de la
ruralité et de la ruralité qui est
importante donc oui il y aura un
ministre compétent en charge de
l'intérieur et de la sécurité publique
bien on passe au micro orange au fond
oui c'est vous madame chivu rat tôt mais
voilà je n'étais pas sûr de la couleur
michel nous avons démarré ensemble et je
suis extrêmement ravi
depuis lui jp luder le rpr de trouver de
trouver quelqu'un qui a une ligne et une
sole et et qui a toujours eu le lan by
sion de cette france que nous aimons
tous
alors ma question va dans le sens de de
ce qui intéresse les jeunes et de ce que
ceux dont aurélien pradié nous a parlé
tout à l'heure dans le sens de
l'environnement nous avons encore une
fois étaient des précurseurs à la
différence des menteurs vers
le haut en face de notre belle plage de
malo les bains dans le nord je suis
délégué de la 13e circonscription à
dunkerque on envisage un parc éolien de
50 kilomètres carrés avec quarante six
éoliennes de 300 mètres de haut la
taille de la tour eiffel sur une zone
historique dynamo en pleine zone natura
2000 alors que personne ne peut
construire dans les dunes etc mais ça ça
ne gêne pas du tout les verts de prévoir
cette
construction d'éoliennes qui pour
lesquels nous avons trouvé cette phrase
les éoliennes plus on en sait moins on
les aime parce que ce n'est pas une
énergie décarbonée
les projets actuels l'ex-maire ghana en
bretagne et cetera ne sont pas encore
complètement avancer ni sortie on n'a
pas encore commencé le bétonnage et
j'aurais aimé savoir si
vous décidiez un moratoire en matière
d'éoliennes puisque vous êtes contre
merci merci beaucoup merci et la
deuxième les environs deuxième question
non non non et malgré ça va dans le même
sens très très con envisage aussi on
envisage au on va construire une usine
de batteries d'ancienne génération
en france alors que l'europe alloue des
crédits pour la recherche et pour les
batteries de nouvelle génération
est ce que on va continuer à laisser
s'implanter des usines chinoises
d'ancienne génération en france au lieu
d'industrialiser notre pays et de
favoriser la recherche pour des
batteries de nouvelle génération
alors
content d'avoir évoqué en
en écoutant les vieux engagements
qui sont les nôtres depuis l'union des
jeunes pour le progrès ya quelques-uns
des anciens militants que je retrouve
avec plaisir
d'abord sur les batteries vous regardez
le projet de détails
je préfère qu'on fabrique des batteries
chez nous
peut-être avec des investissements
étrangers plutôt que d'acheter des
batteries directement aux chinois qui
les fabrique chez eux un
plus d'emplois chez nous c'est toujours
mieux et quand je dis investir en france
et nous qui devons investir c'est nous
qui vont investir
sur ce sujet jeudi en passant parce que
c'est un outil important que je vais
proposer au gouvernement de créer un
fond souverain
peut-être d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière décentralisée sur les idées
élaboré notamment par olivier marc l'ex
qui mobilisera une grande partie de
l'épargné des français qui est
disponible plutôt orienté vers la dette
actuellement notamment l'assurance vie
je pense qu'on peut clairement orienté
encourager ce sera volontaire la
mobilisation de 300 à 400 milliards
d'euros dans un tel fonds souverain qui
investira dans les sujets stratégiques y
compris l'agroalimentaire pour notre
pays qui pourra prendre des
participations et qui sera un levier
mobilisant les pins des français vers
les actifs stratégiques de notre pays
plutôt que vers la dette seulement
sur les éoliennes les choses sont
claires oui on va mettre à plat tous les
projets et à ceux qui sont déjà lancés
il ya une condition claire c'est qu'il y
aura pas d'éoliennes nulle part s'il n'y
a pas un accord des collectivités
territoriales
il faut aussi j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
en répondant aurélien des mots que j'ai
mis dans la loi française la commission
nationale du débat public qui fonctionne
toujours plus ou moins bien mais qui
fonctionne faut s'assurer d'un vrai
débat public j'ai été très frappée en
allant à saint brieuc marc le fur
m'avait invité l'autre jour et de deux
sont des sujets qu'il faut examiner avec
objectivité et sans idéologie moi j'ai
pas d'idéologie mais franchement j'ai
posé des question j'ai écouté toutes les
parties prenantes les élus les personnes
m'a convaincu de l'intérêt économique et
écologique de cette de ce champ
d'éoliennes qu'on veut mettre dans la
baie de saint brieuc personne et c'est
sans doute la même chose chez vous j'en
ai d'ailleurs j'étais d'aller lire
soirée on m'a parlé de ce projet
dans la baie donc je ne suis pas
convaincu de sa et donc on va regarder
de très près je dis pas que tu auras
jamais d'éoliennes nulle part
alors que les allemands les
néerlandais les belges en met partout il
y aura sans doute dans les conditions
que je viens d'évoquer avec l'assurance
qu'il y a un rapport
intérêt écologique intérêt économique
raisonnable est positif il y aura
peut-être des projets qui se verront
journée nous allons marquer un coup
d'arrêt à ces projets les examine et il
est réexaminé
pour ceux qui ne sont pas réalisés de
manière méthodique et objectifs merci
madame au micro rouge s'il vous plaît
rapidement vraiment une minute la
question s'il vous plaît monsieur
barnier bonjour je vous attends si on
était simple jeu celui-ci joue à part de
chez moi pardon
lorsque laurent wauquiez était président
de notre parti vous l'aviez qualifié de
populiste
avez vous changé d'avis à ce sujet
oui
bah je sais pas si j'ai dit ça mais je
ne le dirais plus aujourd'hui parce que
je le pense pas voilà donc
pense qu'il a eu raison d'ailleurs avant
d'autres sera un certain nombre de
sujets voilà
alors vous aurez la démonstration que le
conseiller national est un lieu
d'expression parfaitement
je m'exprime d'ailleurs année avec la
même liberté
charles michel a succédé la liberté qui
imprègne absolument tous nos échanges de
part et d'autre le micro le s'il vous
plaît cela oui parce que c'est ouvert
woman oui c'est tout je suis gabriel
manas je suis le délégué de la troisième
circonscription du 66 une belle
fédération je me suis permis de venir au
micro pour vous poser une question sur
la confiance qui manque des français et
des françaises bien sûr vis-à-vis de
leur classe politique nous avons
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes qui
pensent que nous sommes les mêmes que
les uns et les autres n'ont rien de
nouveau à apporter et que finalement
l'abstention est un recours aujourd'hui
à tant que candidat et demain en tant
que futur président de la république
quels sont les axes quelles sont les
méthodes de votre démarche pour pouvoir
ramener les français a une confiance
politique qui est perdu vis-à-vis de
leurs élus
à 7 me
gabriel c'est une question très très
grave est très important parce qu'elle
est même à la base de toute notre action
politique si on perd la confiance si les
électeurs ne votent plus si l'on
sentiment notamment les jeunes que ça ne
sert plus à rien d'aller voter au niveau
national ce qu'il y à encore
heureusement des raisons
légitimes à aller voter au niveau local
pour des mères ou des présidents
territoriaux qui démontre concrètement
l'utilité du vote et de l'action
publique
là nous sommes dans un
une dérive
absolument dangereuse pour la démocratie
dont profite l'abstention
et puis dont profitent les extrêmes
toujours parce que quand on a plus
confiance
la tentation c'est naturellement de
l'exprimer par de la colère par des
votes de protestation et on sait bien
vers qui ils sont dirigés donc il faut
reconstruire cette confiance et c'est
notre responsabilité c'est pour ça que
j'ai remercié d'ailleurs les amis qui
sont dans cette compétition de la
manière dont nous débattons parce que ça
aussi c'est important si on se divise s
il y avait des querelles au delà de des
petites l'agressivité quotidienne si on
avait des querelles entre nous là pour
le coup on perd la confiance d'abord nos
militants et ensuite des citoyens
quelle est la clé
ça prendra du temps
c'est que qu'a moi je le ferai je fais
attention à ce que je dis pour être
capable de faire ce que j'ai dit et
c'est la première clé de la confiance
que les citoyens se disent
celui-là est sérieux je vous ai dit très
sérieux on peut juger ce qu'il a fait
parce que j'ai un parcours assez long
quand même je n'ai pas besoin qu'on me
rappelle mon âge je le connais
c'est important quel que soit l'âge
qu'on a c'est de garder la même capacité
d' enthousiasme il a une capacité
d'indignation et je vous promets que je
lai
je vous promets que je me pose cette
question et je me la supposée avant
d'être candidat j'étais du conseiller
général j'avais 22 ans j'ai d'ailleurs
battu un curé défroqué à cette époque
j'espère que là où il est m'ont pardonné
mais
je vous promets que j'ai la même
capacité de m'engager de l'enthousiasmé
de m'indigner que celle que j'avais à
cette époque là c'est pour ça que je
suis devant vous mais on peut tout au
long d'un parcours juger des actes
risque que j'ai un jeu je cherche pas à
faire des voeux pieux ou à tromper les
gens je vous pouvez vérifier ce que j'ai
fait en savoie dans les ministères à
bruxelles et voir si oui ou non j'ai
fait ce que j'avais dit voilà je pense
que
parfois des déceptions mais je pense que
ça a été mon attitude donc respecté sa
parole respecter les gens on n'a pas la
science infuse quand on est quand on est
présent dans la république il faut
écouter ça aussi c'est un vrai
changement une vraie rupture que nous
allons imposer par rapport à la pratique
actuelle
thaler a ni parler du parlement où il ya
tellement de capacité de proposer de
contrôler et d'idées mais il n'ya pas
que le parlement localement
partout il y a de bonnes idées que le
pouvoir donc si les citoyens à la base
on sentiment que leur idée remonte ou
directement ou indirectement qu'ils sont
respectés qu'on les écoute comme je
réfléchis à une idée
qui serait celle de trouver le moyen de
consulter les citoyens de manière moins
dramatique que let à référendum il
faudra faire des référendums notamment
sur les migrations et de moi manière
moins banalisée que ça n'est le cas en
suisse
j'ai une idée à laquelle nous
travaillons qui serait celle d'une
journée nationale de consultation
citoyenne ce jour là les mairies serait
ouverte on pourrait aussi voter
électroniquement et ce jour là la mairie
le conseil municipal le conseil
départemental le conseil régional le
gouvernement pourrait poser une question
vient donc plusieurs questions plusieurs
débats
ça serait un temps de respiration avec
les citoyens pourraient peut-être évité
la dramatisation je pense que la vraie
clé un voyage c'est que les gens qui
dirigent ce qu'ils sont élus fassent ce
qu'ils ont dit et pas plus mais pas
moins merci
une dernière question probablement
madame en orange là ou s'il vous plaît
bonjour à tous donc je suis choisi que
perreault je suis délégué de la
troisième circonscription du morbihan je
suis aussi conseillère départementale et
vice-président du de ce beau département
j'ai une question sur les fonctionnaires
je suis d'autant plus à l'aise pour la
poser puisque je suis fonctionnaire de
l'éducation nationale je suis professeur
en poste à l'éducation nationale lors un
lycée professionnel
j'ai écouté vos débats
entre candidats et c'est un point de
différence entre vous je crois au
toujours mieux pas au toujours plus je
crois à moins de fonctionnaires à mieux
de fonctionnaires des fonctionnaires qui
sont mieux rémunérés plus considérés et
je crois que ça doit passer par la
baisse de tous ces fonctionnaires qui
sont dans ses fonctions support qui
regorge aujourd'hui dans tous nos
grandes ministère
alors
alors michel
monsieur monsieur bernier je voulais
savoir comme le choc c'est bien c'est
pas malin
plaisir de vous accueillir plusieurs
fois en bretagne et d'ailleurs et
d'autres candidats bien sûr tous les
candidats je voulais connaître votre
position très claire sur la question
parce que on sent bien aujourd'hui que
dans notre mouvement c'est tabou alors
je crois à ce mouvement du fameux
travailler plus pour gagner plus et
d'encouragement et du directeur
alors
je peux marquer mon accord avec ce que
vous venez de dire
je ne crois pas au toujours plus partout
je ne crois pas non plus haut toujours
moins systématiquement en tout cas le
toujours mieux oui pour l'état et ma
conviction c'est que l'état doit être
réformé mais ce que je veux simplement
dire ce que j'ai dit l'autre jour à la
télévision et peut-être qu'on on
trouvera plus facilement qu'on le croit
un accord entre ceux qui ont des idées
un peu différente actuellement parmi
nous je ne crois pas que ce soit utile
d'annoncer comme un objectif la
suppression de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de postes pour en créer
ailleurs ça doit être le résultat
d'une réforme
construite concertée pas contre les
fonctionnaires mais avec eux on fera pas
cette réforme sans eux et à coup sûr
des postes en trop vous avez dit dans
les services administratifs
philippe le dire est beaucoup mieux que
moi dans l'hôpital quand on compare
entre il l'a dit l'autre jour entre
l'allemagne et la france on voit bien le
poids des services administratifs que
j'ai cité valencienne tout à l'heure par
rapport à l'allemagne des post l'hôtel
des demies soignants
infirmières
ces hommes et ces femmes sont taboues
actuellement 1 g dans leur propre
famille beaucoup de personnes qui sont
dans des déserts médicaux des médecins
ou qu'ils travaillent dans l'hôpital ils
me disent que
l'explosion est là dans l'hôpital
actuellement que des services sont
fermés des opérations ne sont plus
faites parce qu'il ya plus d'aidés
soignants et plus d'infirmières et april
anesthésistes donc des gens partent
parce qu'ils sont mal payés et qu'ils ne
sont pas considérés donc il ya des
redéploiements à faire à coup sûr j'ai
parlé de telle ou telle région la mienne
avec laurent wauquiez où on a réussi à
préserver et même à augmenter la qualité
de service public en diminuant les frais
de fonctionnement
est ce que je veux dire c'est que si on
veut faire cette réforme jeudi le
contrat plutôt que la contrainte les
coudes des gens
il faut pas de mon point de vue je le
ferai pas en tout cas annoncé des
chiffres lâche au rabot qui donne le
sentiment d'une forme de punition on va
faire ça avec le
vais vous donner un exemple de l'endroit
il faut remettre des fonctionnaires par
exemple pour faire du toujours mieux on
me dit que il ya des milliers de
plaintes qui arrive à paris pour
protester contre le fait que notamment
des personnes plus âgées ils ne trouvent
plus à qui parler ni plus de visage et
plus de voix dans l'administration il ya
plus que
démarche par internet
plus de visage et plus de voix la
numérisation
ça veut pas dire la déshumanisation
donc il faut que l'état retrouve dans
certains endroits pour les personnes qui
en ont besoin une voix et un visage donc
voilà nous allons faire ce travail est à
coup sûr il va falloir revaloriser les
métiers comme le vôtre dans l'hôpital
dans l'éducation dans l'art mais aussi
un ya un malaise assez important dans
l'armée actuellement chez les militaires
de base sur leur statut est le manque de
considération donc ce sera la clé ça
sera toujours mieux c'est ça le projet
l'objectif après chaque ministre à son
poste avec les collectivités locales
nous allons réformer l'état
même si cher michel
merci d'être prêté
sinon je dis juste quelques secondes
je sais pas si c'était plus facile de
débuter le conclure ou d'être au milieu
un peu cas j'étais heureuse d'ouvrir ce
jeu des questions réponses je souhaite
bon courage et bon vent à mes quatre
amis concurrents dans cette compétition
je leur confie mais je vous confirme que
en ce qui me concerne je ferai tout pour
qu'on se retrouve dans une seule équipe
et pour un seul projet notre pays est un
grand pays un très grand pays nous avons
moi j'ai une fierté définitive pour ce
pays que j'ai appris tout au début de
mon engagement général de gaulle disait
un grand pays est un pays qui le veut
nous le voulons mais ça ne se fera pas
tout seul il faudra qu'on fasse l'effort
en interne par la réforme par des
ruptures et en externe aussi pour
recréer de l' influence française c'est
à ce à quoi je suis prêt si vous le
voulez et si vous me faites confiance
aux deux cas merci de votre attention de
la diversité de vos amitiés de vaud
proximité de vos fidélité que je
respecte nous allons nous retrouver mais
pour ceux qui le veulent ce qu'ils
mangent juge dignes je vous remercie
pour votre confiance
[Applaudissements]